on va parler les marchés boursiers avec
karine surcote gestionnaire de
portefeuille associé chez medici merci
d'être là madame turcotte
donc on disait il ya un petit instant le
meilleur mois d'août en 36 ans pour les
indices américains c'est comme s'ils
répondent crise du tout le comment on
explique ça il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
eu le mois de mars meilleur mois depuis
mai mois de mars est la moins 20% pour
que vous avez raison il ya une crise et
elle est réelle en même temps c'est une
situation assez particulière parce qu'on
remarque les dommages causés par la
crise actuelle est très bon les dommages
sont inégaux selon secteurs d'activité
économique et on fera les entreprises
dans le secteur technologique au
numérique il par exemple microsoft qui
crochète de certains aspects de la crise
comme la haute télétravail c'est pour
semer dans le côté suivraient dans le
domaine des spectacles on comprend que
vous souffrez énormément alors cette
répartition inégale entre les gagnants
et les perdants pour un actif refuge
dans la moyenne des résultats qui est
teinté de positif et de négatif que je
ne pouvais mais madame sûr quand on dit
souvent c'est ce qu'ont reflète sur les
marchés boursiers c'est ce qu'on prévoit
pour les prochains mois on parle
beaucoup de deuxième vague pourquoi ça
se reflète pas sur les marchés en ce
moment je crois que les gens espèrent ou
pense qu'on va apprendre justement de la
première bagarre on va profiter de
l'expérience de l'apprentissage y avoir
différents dans une deuxième bague g on
doit aussi plusieurs entreprises qui ont
su s'adapter et nous aussi comme ça
c'était on a su s'adapter
peut-être ajouter que les bas taux
d'intérêt ne rend pas la vie facile aux
épargnants qui veulent faire travailler
leur régime de retraite
donc la bourse demeure quand même un
moyen pour avoir un horizon placement à
long terme mais qui est un moteur de
ramage demeure un moteur de rendement
pour un portefeuille comme celui nos
clients donc peut-être ses effets love
ou encore que les chefs surprise aux
attaques wapol peine
par contre ce qu'on me demande s'il ya
eu toute une embellie depuis le creux de
la mi mars
est-ce que ça va se poursuivre est-ce
qu'on pourrait à l'opposé assister à un
décrochage si on devait recommencer à
consigner partiellement l'économie
qu'est ce qui nous attend j'adore votre
question parce que je dois répondre que
oui on prépare nos clients il faut
toujours se préparer à un décrochage
donc ça serait la france est
imprévisible en mai que le marché va
nous nous offrit un court terme et ceux
qui ont essayé au mois de mars de
justement prévoir comment la crise
allait évoluer au niveau des marchés et
qui ont vendu dans un mauvais moment
qu'on dit toujours de me forster ont pu
manquer effectivement la rose qui était
très rapide donc c'est imprévisible
et oui vous avez raison qu'on peut
appeler un autre décrochage pour qu'il
ya des impacts pour les entreprises mais
à la fin tout ça nous on est maintenant
les entreprises qu'on évalue et comment
on veut y en a qui sont plus impacté que
d'autres là qui vont profiter donc ça
petit crédit le portique rien que des
croche mais vous avez raison qu'il faut
s'attendre à ça et on garde en tête que
ça va être imprévisible et il faut sera
menée pour notre horizon de placement
qui est à long terme et l'adaptation des
entreprises donc choisir les bons
joueurs et réévaluer qu'elle pour les
bons choix en parlant de joueurs qui en
ont profités dans les dernières semaines
les derniers mois on va parler de tesla
est à pau deux entreprises qui
aujourd'hui fractionne leur action
rapide est ce que ça implique exactement
oui parce qu'on se rend compte qu'ils
voient que c'est un événement bien
compris mais c'est très simple et à paul
est un bon exemple parce que je vais
vous dire que vous avez une action par
exemple d'apports afin que tant de
l'ouest avant le fractionnement et on va
faire comme si cette action est une
pomme justement à ce don comme pizza ou
les sharks mais l'on veut dire de
novembre exactement
et là je vais vous la couper en quatre
quartiers
vous n'avez pas d'argent on ne pas créer
de valeur par le fractionnement on a
augmenté le nombre d'annoncés 1 kl à son
rôle en or on a mis des quartiers de
pommes donc des pompes vous n'avez pas
une plus grosse pourquoi on fait ça là
en fait madame sûr que si ça donne pas
plus de valeur qu'est ce que qu'est-ce
que ça
ange on ouvre l'horizon parce que ça
devient plus accessible c'est ça oui
dans le fond au niveau de la liquidité
c'est sûr que l'on parle à fond par
exemple à 500 $ us
est ce que c'est possible ou pas bon ça
pourrait débarquer mais oui en terme de
liquidités d'accessibilité pour tous
pour éviter percevoir comme si le titre
était moins chère des points d'eau qu'on
lit les termes pour favre amateurs donc
effectivement obtenez qui ne fait pas
une vie du lion en plusieurs morceaux
ouais par contre bon j'ai passé tous les
investisseurs nous écoute mais ça
entraîne souvent une hausse du titre
dans les jours qui suivent mais ça c'est
un autre dossier
juste un petit mot en terminant sur des
changements pour le dow jones
aujourd'hui on éjecte des géants exxon
mobil en trop et on remplace sa part du
nouveau qu'est ce qui change
mais dans le pommeau le lundi doit
représenter comme il faut son économie
donc l'économie américaine et le
façonnage cela convient de parler d'un
port vous l'avais dit la salle entraîner
des hausses importantes pour savoir si
c'est justifié par d'ajustement est un
fondamental dans le cadre de ce nombre à
en débattre
par rapport à abomey ce fractionnement
loeb dans le d'argent de fait diminuer
le poids du secteur technologique dans
les haies et ils ont remplacé par nos
forces
le côté d'exxon qui était condamné lundi
soir malheureusement doit sa relative
mais je vous remercie pour vos
explications
c'est bon merci beaucoup en forêt